The Windows operating system contains
comprehensive anti virus and
anti-malware functionality in Microsoft
Defender Antiirus. This is integrated
into the operating system and installed
and turned on by default. You'll find
all of the information about Windows
Defender Antiirus under the Windows
Security app, specifically the section
for virus and threat protection.
Depending on the version of Windows
you're using, you could see different
names for this application. It might be
called Defender Antiirus, Windows
Defender, or the name that's used
currently, Microsoft Defender Anti
Virus. If you're looking for the Windows
Security app, you can go to the search
option within Windows 11. Type security
and it should be the option right at the
top called Windows Security app. When
this starts, you'll see a number of
different features, including account
protection, firewall and network
protection, app and browser control, and
others. But for our purposes in this
video, we're going to talk about the
virus and threat protection option at
the upper left. If we click that, we'll
get more details on Windows Defender
Antiirus. For the vast majority of your
work inside of Windows, you will want to
leave this function enabled. You never
want to turn off your anti virus or
anti-malware capability because it is
very easy for one of those malware apps
to sneak into your system without you
knowing it. This is something you might
need to turn off if you're simply doing
some temporary troubleshooting and you
want to be sure that the problem you're
having is not associated with Defender
Antiirus. The default configuration for
Defender Antivirus is to run with
realtime protection. This means that it
will monitor and scan for all file
transfers that are occurring in and out
of your operating system and it will
automatically identify any malicious
software that may be contained within
those documents. If for some reason you
need to turn off this real-time
protection, you'll find this under the
Windows security app under the virus and
threat protection settings. If you go to
the manage settings section, you can
enable and disable real time protection.
We're back on my Windows machine and
under virus and threat protection, I'm
going to scroll down past the current
threats and move down under virus and
threat protection settings. There's an
option here for manage settings and
we'll click on that. We can enable and
disable real-time protection, cloud
delivered protection, automatic sample
submission, tamper protection, control
folder access, and define any
exclusions. If you'd like to disable
this function, let's scroll all the way
back to the top where it says real time
protection. You can see it is set on by
default. We will click that option and
Windows will give us a user account
control window telling us that it's
about to make a major change to the
operating system. And it asks, do you
want to allow this app to make changes
to your device? This would be the
Windows security app from Microsoft
Windows. And we would like to yes, make
changes. And you can see that has now
turned off real time protection. This
also puts a notice on this page that
says real time protection is off,
leaving your device vulnerable just so
you're aware of the concerns associated
with disabling that functionality. The
process for reenabling real-time
protection is the same process. We go to
the toggle that says off. We click it.
It asks if we would like to make changes
to our device. We would. And now real
time protection is back on.
Many anti virus applications rely on a
set of signatures to be able to identify
this malicious software. So in order to
catch the latest version of viruses and
malware, we need the latest version of
definitions. Normally these definitions
are downloaded automatically. But there
may be times when you would like to
force a check of those definitions to
confirm that you really are running the
latest version. You would find this
option in Defender Antivirus under the
threat and protection updates section
and there is an option to check for
updates. On that next page, you'll find
a button that will allow you to check
for updates. You can also manage the
automatic update process from that
screen as well. Back on our Windows
configuration, we are in our Windows
security app under virus and threat
protection. I'm going to scroll down
just a bit to where it says virus and
threat protection updates. And I'm going
to click the option for protection
updates. From this window, it tells us
about the latest updates that have been
installed, the security intelligence
version number, when that version was
created, and when the last update was
made. If we click check for updates, it
will go out and check for the latest
version of those updates. If there have
been new definitions, it will download
those definitions and install them into
your currently running version. Now that
our updates are successful, you can see
there is a new version of the signatures
that was installed and updated on this
Windows 11 device.